if you want drama let's have drama with
this take a look at the story from from
the Free Press
I thought I was saving trans kids now
I'm blowing the whistle there are more
than 100 pediatric gender clinics across
the U.S I worked at one what's happening
to Children is morally and medically
appalling I mean that's the gist of her
story it's a woman who worked for four
years at a clinic as a case manager
responsible for patient intake and
oversight I left the clinic in November
last year because I could no longer
participate in what was happening there
by the time I departed I was certain
that the way the American Medical system
is treating these patients is the
opposite of the promise to do no harm
instead we are permanently harming the
vulnerable patients in our care the I
I'm segueing here but I want to mention
this is the kind of story that makes me
be like guys you know what man I will I
will eat Humble Pie I will do whatever I
I need your help on this one I don't
want to fight with people about about
drama stuff we shouldn't do that I
shouldn't do that I'll do I'll say
whatever I have to say to to calm
everybody out to chill to chill
everybody out and that's on me I'll take
that because this is the kind of stuff
that makes me feel like
look look
I've been talking on this channel for a
long time about just getting the van
down by the river and just letting it
all go away and the problem with that is
every time I imagine how how much more
fun in a sense my life would be if I
just said I'm done working 16 hour days
I'm done running a company I'm gonna go
hang out by the river and just catch
some fish and just breathe the fresh air
and then I think about five years after
that
people will be locked up in camps kids
will be getting castrated money will be
worthless and I'm like yeah if we stop
doing what we're doing or if we turn on
each other
this is the kind of stuff that doesn't
get exposed I believe this woman who's
coming out here is coming out now and
saying hey what they're doing to kids is
wrong is likely doing it not completely
because of the work that we do or people
like like the quartering or whatever but
partially as a grain of sand making that
Heap the more we promote individuals
calling this out the more people will
wake up to what the cult is yeah and if
we do nothing and if we fight with each
other and I'll take responsibility on
that if I keep doing that if I keep
getting pissed off and telling people to
go screw themselves I'm going to wake up
one day in a world where this is the
norm 100 I just spent the past week in
La working with you know doing ATR stuff
and I know a lot of the very
left-leaning people and and you know
spending time in Los Angeles and
Hollywood and stuff those are the kind
of people that you run into and
even people that you would consider
left-leaning they have kids and they
hear about this kind of stuff and
they're just like yo no this is this is
where I draw the line and they don't
want to talk about it in public they
don't want to admit it because it's you
know it's a dangerous thing to to be
just to condemn this kind of stuff
because there's all kinds of
associations that people on the left
make if you condemn this this some these
kind of gender surgeries
um gender assignment synergies
um but parents are over it parents don't
want it doesn't matter if they're left
or right parents are are strongly of the
opinion that this stuff is bad and
without people like this show like the
people that we have on here pushing back
on this stuff people don't come out and
say hey this stuff is bad they don't
have the the intestinal fortitude or
whatever to stand up and say hey no I'm
I really have this uh this this of this
this problem with these procedures and
stuff so it is important Matt Walsh went
down to Loudoun County and he spoke
about critical race Theory and gender
ideology in these schools it is this
kind of work where look man I don't
agree with Matt Walsh on a lot of things
all right he's a he's a bold guy to put
him outly but I think you know in in
a future where there is factions of Matt
Walsh's the disagreements we have is
sitting at a table and him being like
look Tim I just don't agree with you on
on how we're going to be implementing a
policy like that and then me saying
things like well look I don't know but
you know I'll see The Ballot Box whereas
today it's people
bringing kids in for castration you know
what I mean I wonder about you guys you
know Jose and Reed like I think of you
guys as the Pinnacle of libertarianism
and I wonder how do you deal with this
kind of clip that it's about when you
live about that I don't know if you call
libertarian hands off but when you live
like you live your life I'll live mine
how do you what do you do when a parent
across the road wants to cut their kids
genitals off and turn them into another
gender yeah so I'm all about cultural
repulsion basically I think that's the
strongest the strongest way to go like
in New Hampshire uh we're really trying
to create a culture of obnoxious Liberty
as Phil can attest to not just the
Twitter account but just in general
abominable snowmen up in New Hampshire
the only reason this has taken off is
because the cultural sensibility is
allowing it to go on and handling these
people with kid gloves if we push back
and said oh yeah it's ridiculous that
you want to uh you know mess with the
endocrine system of a young child at a
point where their endocrine system is
already influx and mutilate their
genitals and in a point where they're
not really in any sort of stage to give
any sort of meaningful consent in their
life yeah I don't think it's that crazy
but like hey yeah you're you're not like
to be essentially a bully to to push
back culturally the opposite way and I
mean I'm not saying do violence to these
people or anything like that but there's
no reason you need to accept that as a
narrative because that's okay there are
people constantly saying that they're so
glad that they left New Hampshire
because it's such a Libertarian idiots
or whatever and we're all like good
we're glad you left and they I mean they
have protests where they're calling free
Staters Vermin invasive species that
need to be exterminated that's what
they're saying about us this is because
you guys troll people yeah because we're
so obnoxious and by the way to be clear
I'm not saying to do that to adults who
have made this choice on their own I
mean I have my personal opinions it's
probably a little bit ridiculous if you
start like
you know but like snip snip but you know
so far it's your life at that point do
what you want I don't care Dave Smith
made a great point when he said that
stigma is how you peacefully discourage
uh behavior that you don't like and so
the idea that libertarianism equals
libertine uh government we bully them a
lot yeah Libertines what's that well so
just because something is legal doesn't
mean that you have to endorse it and
that's one of the things that people
that have it you know you call them
state or we call them status or whatever
but like that's what a status tends to
think if you say I don't think this
should be illegal they automatically in
their brain jumped at the conclusion
that you endorse the behavior and so I
don't think that it should be illegal
for people to get uh you know to get
gender reassignment surgery that's fine
you know you live your life go ahead you
know that's that's totally fine but
there's nothing wrong with stigmatizing
people that want to have children or
young adults get gender reassignment
surgery and condemning the idea of
teenagers and and children getting
gender reassigner surgery that's
something that Society should do there
are challenges to any kind of like like
the idea of cosmetic surgery is is a
gradient it's not yes or no it's not
black or white so if we would we could
ask a few questions to explore the
morality of uh transgender surgeries and
plastic surgery in general is it okay
for an 18 year old human being to have
their hand surgically removed
18 I say I mean because of the fact that
you have to have an arbitrary line I
guess 18 but I mean you're not fully
developed well I mean a legal adult yeah
you you think it's okay do you would you
guys I mean I don't wanna it's an age of
consent conversation no she did not say
those three words it should be legal but
it should be condemned like people
shouldn't support the idea people
shouldn't encourage it and doctors
shouldn't say let's go ahead and cut
your hand off like we I mean it should I
don't think that we should have what do
you guys think I agree should it be
illegal for adults to have their hands
surgically removed I think the ethical
thing for a doctor is to not do it
because and I think you know stigma
comes in play if they do do it they get
shunned upon by the doctors Community
other people in the community
Etc this is where the Ron Paul argument
about heroin comes in he he told a bunch
of Republicans and what was that 2012 in
South Carolina like if heroin was legal
today how many of you would go shoot up
right now and the whole crowd was like
yeah none of us would so I mean No One's
Gonna like cut off their and you know I
mean they will yeah it's called some
general General body dysmorphic disorder
something that affect where people they
feel like they're I talked about this
with the the Twitter 1.0 Executives when
they were when they were talking about
how they got to protect trans people
because they're having an identity
identity crisis that results in in
depression and potentially suicide I
said the same is true for General body
dysmorphia anorexic for instance people
are starving themselves to death or
people who overeat and become morbidly
obese and have heart attacks but also
people who want to have their limbs
removed and they do there are many
stories of uh there's one guy who had
like a tree fall in his arm so that he
could justify amputation because he
wanted it removed from his body so he
cut it down on top of his arm something
like that happened yeah he had it fall
in his arms that he could justify
removing it or something that effect or
I think he smashed with a hammer and
then claimed something like that
happened and he needed to get it removed
there are people who are experiencing
this and there are questions about what
is the best way to provide assistance to
them if there is no you know and this is
where I suppose I'm more liberal and
less libertarian
if the Opera if the law exists you could
shun a guy all day and night but if he's
getting paid the money for it he doesn't
care what you think well here's the
thing like I'm I've been a blue collar
worker for the last 10 years of my life
and every time some anomaly takes place
OSHA thinks they have to regulate it
away from ever happening again instead
of accepting people are stupid and
they're gonna make mistakes and dumb
stuff is going to happen and having a
very you know reasonable set of
guidelines they make it so now you have
to wear a harness when you're four feet
in the air
so I'm just saying that like
justifying a law because of red herrings
just leads you to a place of stupidity
it's I don't think it's a red herring
because those are those are things that
actually happen like they're actually
the question about the hand removing the
hand is a question of can you pay a
doctor to remove a healthy body part and
the answer right now is for the most
part yes that's not how you actually
help a person who's suffering from
somebody dysmorphia you so what happens
is hey man you if the money is good good
but if someone is I'll put it I'll put
it this way because it doesn't include
death uh what we often talk about is the
Golden Gate Bridge and every person
who's jumped off it and survived has
explained that the one they immediately
regretted it and the one thing going
through their mind was all of life's
problems could be solved except for
having jumped off the bridge and so if
they jump off and they end up regretting
it and they live we learn that if
someone says I need my hand removed and
then they regret it what do we do it's
it's you're never getting it back and
you had that one Doctor Who said uh that
woman who said of children who get
mastectomies if they want if they want
breasts when they're older they can just
get implants like that's not the same
thing you've lost them this is where a
stigma comes in uh a good example I have
a business I I breed hairless cats I
know it sounds silly but we we deal with
clients we sell them and this is where
stigma comes in yes sir you could have
the concept of hey uh you know the
money's good that's it but we even have
turned down business many times because
we're like I don't like this client I
don't like the idea that this person is
going to have my my pet and they're
going to be a representation of my brand
and and vice versa like we also have to
upkeep a certain standard have a clean
cat room a nice presenting house because
we want to have a good looking brand
because we don't want to be looked at as
like crap so like the idea that uh and
I'm not trying to like crap on you or
anything but I'm just saying like the
idea that's just like oh as long as the
money's good there's a whole lot more
that goes into that and yes on an
individual level there still will be
like in our there's definitely people
that go so hairless catch for like 500
bucks which is like criminally low for
them and and it's just gross like and
those are going to exist but in the long
run that is not a good way to upkeep
what you're doing because it's just it
doesn't work like but there will be
individual situations that system works
best thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time